I put myself in a position where I could
get a record deal where I could find
somebody where I could call somebody
where I could say hey can I buy you for
five million - ruff I apologize it's the
name of the show thank you very much
[Music]
everybody it's a it's Gary again back
with another episode of my nice show
that I'm super excited about called
interrupted by Gary Vee
today's guest is Jesse it's ler an
entrepreneur but I'm gonna let him frame
it up for you and then I'm gonna fire
away with a bunch of questions but first
and foremost Jess thanks for being on
thanks for having me appreciate it so
tell the vaynernation that's listening
right now who you are great well I'm a
serial entrepreneur I started out in the
music business I had a I was signed to a
record label called delicious vinyl in
the 90s what year did you suck I signed
in 1990 I was 21 and what kind of artist
were you don't laugh I was a rapper I'm
aware I can see it for everybody who's
listening you'll hear some laughs in the
background and things that make sure
we're here an off-site kind of
conference thing so we're just recording
the podcast in between sessions so keep
going Jess so you're your rapper at 21
started out right did you grow up I grew
up in Long Island and then I went to
school in Washington DC at American
University got a record deal good test
taker maybe I don't know about smart but
fair enough got a record deal right out
of college after a lot of rejection
scientist delicious final got dropped
from the label
a year later why sales and just wasn't
the right thing a tough timing I was
behind Vanilla Ice and I wasn't you know
nearly as good as there was the best
thing that ever happened to me the worst
thing at the time cuz I only had two
things on my resume after that I was a
kiddie pool attendant and I was a rapper
and that's not gonna get you a lot of
job and the rapper thing go down how old
are you gonna be 52 hey you look great
so 52 so you're eight years older me so
when does rap hit your radar rap hits my
radar in right away man right when it
came on the scene
I was probably my just I don't know 16
15 so early 80s I heard it's like that
buy Run DMC sucker MCs buy Run DMC fell
in love with it grew up in Long Island
where hip-hop was like emerging fast yes
and just got the bug so started out
breakdancing started out
in the you know just doing whatever I
could do this is a different era you
know maybe and just got into it and when
everybody in college was like making
resumes and setting resumes the
companies I'm like I'm getting a record
deal I don't need a resume and at that
time I've never been in a studio I own
you an entrepreneurial kid I was an
insane kid I got tried everything my
parents gave me a long leash and I just
tried anything and they allowed me and
supported me to do anything like that
but I wouldn't say I was a sharp
entrepreneur I was another paper route
right wasn't no but I was just I was
it's not looking to make money I was
looking for adventure man I was looking
for fun and I still AM but I was never
really wired for to make money so what
did your crew look like were you like a
skateboard kid - I was I was athletic
okay um I was artistic I was a good
storyteller and I wasn't scared I wasn't
scared to fail was hard to try because
my parents really just supported my
effort they praised my effort and not
the results and did they acknowledge
when you failed they praised the effort
so we got blown out of a basketball game
or if I had a great game or a bad game
it was like you tried so hard and
they've always praised the effort and as
a father of four that's something that
we do with our kids it's all about the
effort where do you think what do you
think the Mendoza line is on praising
effort and making one appreciate process
versus creating delusion when one is not
good at that thing well I think the the
fine line in between those two points is
disappointment and I think
disappointments been stripped from kids
great there's participation trophies I
get you know everyone's on it you know
you can make this so your parents on the
way home of losing a game 42 to 16 we're
like hey I really appreciate the fact
that you were down by 30 that you were
going hard but in the same token they
weren't making excuses or saying you're
gonna be Michael [ __ ] Jordan yeah but
my pet my dad on the plumbing supply
house man my dad didn't even get that
deep into it all right it's like he took
me to the game
you watched it and then he went and he
sold Plumbing Supplies let me talk its
course he talked but he wasn't there
wasn't about like raising this kid
that's gonna go to Harvard or that's
gonna be an amazing athlete it was Sol
anyway
went hard and you get in the car and he
says good job kid
he says how'd you feel about it you know
I really do yeah and like I said I feel
terrible we got blown out right and then
he'd say like well you know you did
great and keep keep trying and that kind
of stuff
my father wasn't the kind of person that
put any kind of pressure on me to
succeed is he was a Family Guy
he still is and it was just about that
that and mom teacher and then raised
four kids and what was she saying to you
same thing it was just she said oh you
look so cute in your shorts like what
she like that kind of mom my mom was she
was like he looks great - it was like
thanks mom
something was like 16 when I first
realized wait a minute I'm not the
best-looking person on earth like like
would she like that kind of mom she was
she they really gave me my distance and
they let me figure it out are you and
against the bottom four got it it's cool
though it's very it is cool like they've
been through enough reps where I'm sure
you're oh is it a sister or brother
that's the oldest brother had it
slightly different yeah yeah it was the
best kind of childhood for me though man
there was no I didn't feel any pressure
to have to do you know what they did
they put the pressure on me they might
not putting the prob a made me want it
for me like it can't be my parents dream
it would had to be my dream I get it and
they never I remember when I wanted to
get good grades from my parents migrated
sucked when I was like I want to do good
good get good grades so I could like get
to a good school for me they skyrocketed
so they took the pressure off of me
the freedom Creighton there was my goal
hmm I was my dream so now you get signed
tell them about the New York Knicks oh I
get signed to this label called
delicious vinyl I wrote a couple of
songs for an artist named tone Lok I get
dropped from the label a year later I
moved back to New York City I have two
things on my resume I was a kiddie pool
attendant and I was a rapper and but
you're my wife always says this is so
true you find your passion at the
intersection of what it is you love to
do and what you're good at and providing
a product that people like or enjoy I
love sports and music so I marry those
two things and I wrote a theme song for
the New York Knicks
go near Co I was 22 and the Knicks paid
me $4,000 for the song it costs me
$4,800 to do the song he asked me if I
was into money not real I lost $800 on
my first dick trade but the reality is I
would have paid the Knicks 10 grand to
do the song and the song became the
number one most requested song on New
York radio and that took off as a 44
year old Knicks fan you can't imagine
what that song actually is it was it was
being played while the Knicks made a run
and actually got to the NBA Finals lost
unfortunately seven games to the Rockets
but like I probably heard that song 8000
times seven thousand eight hundred of
them were in a four-week period in 1994
yes it was insane it was the same like
that became York like tell me living
that moment we're like Jean 1994 you're
eight years old Ernie so you're 22 yeah
22 23 are you basically you know the
Internet's not around so people don't
know [ __ ] the same way like are you just
walking around life and before you even
say hi you telling people that you wrote
that [ __ ] song I would be yeah well
it was interesting because at that point
in my life I slept on 18 different
couches yep so I had 18 different
friends I bounced around for a week here
at a couch couch couch couch and then
all the sudden I wrote this song and
it's the number one song you know at the
time it was big and big in New York
uncomfortably big yeah and I didn't
really know how to handle that weight
you know but everyone was asking me for
playoff tickets and I had no money I was
sleeping on couches and you know what I
did I got everybody playoff tickets
that's cool yeah I'm on my credit card
and I realized that in an early age that
to be a connector and not having to ask
for anything in return and just I knew
it would come back tenfold and I wanted
to be the guy that could get anything
done you know that was what you wanted
to stand for
I still do anything like there's no
obstacle there's no business there's no
goal there's no race so how much in
playoff tickets do you end up spending
enough that a kid it set me back but but
again those seats those seeds you know
what Hey yeah they paid off later so
what happened next
so all the sudden I was like whoa
as an entrepreneur guys we have a lot of
entrepreneur in this in this room you
realize that you look for something that
differentiates yourself and this was a
big differentiator for me I was like no
one else is doing sports music
everyone's trying to be vanilla ice at
the time or whatever but no one's
writing theme songs for pro sports teams
so that was my aha moment and I started
I set up a company to write theme songs
for other teams everything and I'm like
I ended up doing almost every team and
then I sold that company in the NBA MBA
and some baseball football what was the
most next famous song well what happened
was the songs became somewhat popular in
each region but that I turned it into
selling them as a compilation with all
the songs but in its own reach I mean
Chicago because the Jordan came back
there was no right back in it but I sold
almost a million units so it became a
business and I sold that company to a
public company and in that transaction
did you make some money yes did you have
to work there for a little bit
I worked we didn't earn out so I worked
there for a year and a half and then we
hit the air now talk to me about that
year and a half well in our contract
they paid us a couple million dollars up
front but we had a 16 million dollar
trigger if we hit X amount in profit so
we literally had a calendar we three
years to do it and I'm like every day it
was like I was about 360 four more days
man we gotta hit this number every day
was the countdown
yeah and uh that's how I mean it and we
hit it so you were wildly motivated
interests aligned yeah Dave you hit it
you're out what happens next
now you have some money what happened
there how old are you I'm 20 at the time
maybe 26 and you have some money mm-hmm
like way more than you ever have before
yeah and in my family and do you go
crazy no [ __ ] what do you do no I mean
my life my life was is pretty simple
it's pretty simple and pretty simple now
but I was still 26 27 years old but what
happened was the guy that bought our
company had a timeshare in a private jet
and he invited me at 27 years old on
through his private plane it was like
when I walked
it was like if you guys saw the Wizard
of Oz it was like the scene of The
Wizard of Oz when everything goes from
black and white to color it's like
people fly like this they look you got
to be kidding me I want to fly like this
so by the time we landed my partner now
like let's start a private jet company
so we can fly on private planes when we
travel it's like definitely except we
had no airplanes but but we had an idea
and we took that idea it was that
partner his name is Kenny Dichter and we
took that idea to how do you mean Kenny
Kenny what so I own the trademark to all
these themes so as long as I was writing
for the sports teams were popular but
the trademarks were more valuable so go
New York go is being used by Budweiser
footlocker all these big companies and I
wasn't getting any money because I sold
the song for 4 grand so I got smarter
and I started licensing the song and
keeping the marks Kenny owned the
clothing company so I'm like we make
pony Orko t-shirts and hats and we
started working together and you know
built a big business out of it then I
was the guest I'm like let's start a
private chat company Mike he was like
definitely and we took the meeting with
a company called NetJets owned by Warren
Buffett the largest private jet company
in the world first you get to that
meeting
it's just crazy story man the president
of NetJets daughter had a sweet 16 and
christina aguillera was performing and
through somebody that knew me they knew
that I knew the manager and called up
and like this guy wants to do special
for his daughter and like I said nothing
is impossible I called up and the next
day at the concert she was a background
singer with the mic off and he called me
up he's like I don't know who the [ __ ]
you are or what you do but my daughter
is a hero in our town if you ever need
anything let me know
a year later I need 650 airplanes Jim
remember christina aguillera story alike
that was me and I see you on Friday
Friday comes we go we have the meeting
and it lasted about 12 minutes and the
CEO rich Santoli said literally threw us
out there's a direct quote and it really
pissed me off he said if you think I'm
giving to guys who probably didn't break
a thousand on their SAT which really
pissed if I got a 980 on my SAT so it
really bothered me he's like that's
never happened he threw us out
and then the president Jim who I got his
daughter hooked up grabbed me and said
that was unbelievable so we got thrown
out in 12 minutes he goes Santa newley
doesn't give anyone 12 minutes I believe
in this but bring it to life come back
next week so we came back next week and
we realized like we could never sell
this idea and the PowerPoint this this
guy's needs 100 powerpoints and
entrepreneurs have to differentiate so
we brought in our own focus group and we
set up a table by the boardroom table
and one by one we had 8 people come Carl
banks from the New York Giants run from
Run DMC a powerful female real-estate
mogul in New York and one by one they
stood up and they said they never buy a
fraction what NetJets was selling but
they buy a 25 hour jet card what we were
offering and he gave us a deal and a
year later we did 5 billion dollars in
sales then what happens then life
changed the chips are purple and you
know money's interesting man it's
interesting we all play for it we all
want it but we don't really even know
what we're playing for or why we want it
and then we get it and it's confusing
and my relationship we think of
relationships in terms of people has a
relationship with your mom and your dad
we don't think of relationships in terms
of money and time and I have a very good
understanding of my relationship with
time I know you just post that and talk
on that for a while and money and all of
a sudden I came into a lot of money and
I was single and I era and I had
airplanes and I was in New York I could
go on a date with this lady I feel like
if it was going good I'd like you want
to go to Canada what do you want to do
I'd be like people are going to studio
54 trying to get to studio 54 I'm like
let's go to Hawaii tonight
so I had a great decade fair enough and
then what happened
and then I decided that I don't want to
sell airplanes anymore like that wasn't
I didn't feel like I felt like I wanted
to make a quarter by myself than a
seventy five cents in the city in the
company I was in I want to go out on my
own so I was training for a hundred mile
run I realized I signed up for the USA
national ultramarathon championship
because you didn't have to qualify you
could just send $50 registration and
you're in the national championship and
I'm like I'm competing in the national
championship it's [ __ ] unbelievable
then I googled how do you run a hundred
mile race and it came back with a year
everything came back with me how did
that even hit your radar to enter I went
to a crazy period of time and I was
thinking about giving all my money away
I was thinking about charity I was just
like I just you know just trying to
figure it trying to figure it out and I
was like I want to do something big for
charity and like I don't have a big sale
or a golf outing my friends are all
having Act foursome yep and I'm gonna
force some guy so my turn relax yeah
just trying to help the kids at home
good I want to run a hundred miles
without stopping yes so I was like and
what would be the biggest race to do
that in for me it was the national
championship so I googled it it gave me
everything was like a year training
program the race was in 90 days so I
went from basically couch to 100 miles
in 90 days and during the training I did
a lot of research around hydration and
nutrition and everything pointed to
coconut water so I became the human
guinea pig for coconut water and like
here was us this was in 2008 six 2006
because when you run 100 mile it's like
how many calories are taking an hour how
much sodium how many fluid ounces do I
need coconut water was the solution so
anyway I finished the race but I got to
mile 83 I had 7 toenails floating around
in my shoe but I don't ago sheet my
goals like we don't negotiate our goals
in this room like whatever our goal is
it's unwavering and like the plot might
change and the script might
but the goal doesn't change it's not
like my goal wasn't 87 miles or 83 miles
so I finished it and then I was like
this coconut water [ __ ] man there's
something to this like by the way I was
in a wheelchair for four days after the
race but I did finish it and I spent a
year trying to figure out if photos yeah
they were posted yeah that's a good hold
did a documentary on it good you know
yep anyway long story short I spent a
year trying to figure out how to import
coconut order and I did get a 980 on my
SAT I cuz I could I couldn't figure that
[ __ ] out man it was way over my head but
I knew I couldn't spell coconut right
okay keep going you would've been a
great partner for me clearly but I knew
I could market and sell it so I
partnered with a company called Zico z
ICO they were doing about three million
dollars in sales at the time you know
one of the things as an entrepreneur is
figuring out how to get from point A to
B the fastest you know and for me the
learning curve was too great so
partnering was the fastest way so I
partner with Zico and two years later we
sold at the coke and I got married I
married an entrepreneur on my own my
wife owns a company called Spanx which
is a big deal here in the States and
internationally too and and that's where
I am and then what I started shifting my
life to think about changing my show -
and then what good ice I started
focusing putting more on my plate of the
things I love to do with the people I
love to do them with so my life shifted
it didn't really shift because it's
always been this way actually you just
put the energy into a different bucket
the energy was actually always there but
I started really obsessing on
experiences and it's just really
obsessing on almost like living a manic
life is that how you ended up in Atlanta
the coke transaction no my wife's
business in Atlanta understood I shifted
way after the sales to like really
becoming more experience and being
intentional about what yellows their
life was the coconut water sale 2013 ok
ish yeah and the coconut water deal was
interesting because we were the first
company ever I believe or at least
publicly to actually go to
again how do you get from A to B the
fastest to go to influencers and
celebrities like Gisele and Kelly Ripa
mmm and take money in his investors in
exchange for for equity for doing more
stuff like $0.50 got $0.50 got equity
yep in vitamin vitamin water these guys
wrote checks so it's a really authentic
yeah and customers are smart now man
they can see through endorsements so we
had these like real people that really
believed in a real brand ambassadors and
it worked we sold it pretty fast and now
I got four kids we're part owners the
Atlanta Hawks which you know yep we live
in Atlanta and I guess is the epicenter
of culture in America yeah maybe the
world even for that matter
yeah well it's a really dynamic time in
Atlanta for me like just like it's been
really fun to watch it for the last
decade it's just very clear to me in
importance of business because I think
business is a byproduct of what is
established in culture popular culture
in America starts in Atlanta I really
believe that it's an amazing city when I
think about what hip-hop actually means
to the world and where the innovation
and it's just--it's and then you start
layering in the tax breaks that are now
in place for Hollywood and just the
Hollywood infrastructure that's being
built it's just a really interesting
time in Atlanta yeah I feel fortunate to
be a part of it and I feel fortunate to
have been raised in New York because I
think New York gave me a lot of edge a
lot of competitiveness and helped me
just get over my fear man you couldn't
get swallowed in New York if you're
walking around skates right what do you
think what's what's you know hearing
that background and a lot of people you
know hear that it's obviously you know I
think this is what you know we don't
even really know each other that that
well and I think our relationship is
like so good because I think it's bound
on this intuitive creative
entrepreneurial execution I think we
have more similarities than we don't but
obviously we have differences what it's
what leads me to this question what's
just hot take what are four to seven
observations that you think are
interesting right now in the world
through the lens of entrepreneurship
like individual person platform what
somebody's doing what's like on your
radar well I think as a consumer of
energy around [ __ ] like this I think
that a lot of entrepreneurs have been
tricked into thinking that things happen
quickly and you know for me my journey
was different and I remember going to
coke when we had Zico and the president
of coke said it takes 8 years to build a
brand in this country and I was like
eight years like you know I live in dog
years everything's time so I'm like I'm
eight years is forever
and I feel like every year for me is
four years literally the way I live my
life so I feel like that's in the speed
of your execution I just feel like I've
done 200 years worth of stuff in 50
years but I feel like entrepreneurs are
feel like it's get rich quick and
everything has to be quick and we try to
cut corners and that all but that's just
the vibe that I'm getting and because we
live in an age of likes and instant and
fast and speed and that's amazing but
there's also that leads to
disappointment like it takes time and
that's okay to build the foundations of
a long-lasting business I think what
what we've glossed over and you touched
on it lightly with the tickets is a lot
of your execution you know what it's
really cool to get the meetings with the
jet company what's more interesting to
me is why those really fancy people
would go to that meeting and sit there
you built up equity through
relationships with takes time to be able
to convert that energy for that
execution yeah yes
right yeah I mean why did why did Carl
banks and run and all these people why
did they go let me tell you why I'm
gonna tell you why people buy into
stories people and momentum more than
products always so you're the business
plan you're the business plan like we
had momentum and we had a story and when
you have a story that's exciting but
even taking it for yes yeah but what I'm
curious about is buying the tickets on
your credit card you're right how does
one who's listening right now get in
front of the Carl banks and the run of
their day gun
right now get in front of gonna and Von
Miller right now for everybody who's
listening is a disconnect I want to go
into that because I would argue the seed
of so much of this foundation is within
that you put yourself in a position
where luck can find you you put yourself
in a position where you attract luck so
like when I was 21 years old man I had
nothing I wasn't the man I wasn't like
broke but I had nothing I was staying on
couches my office was the Beverly Hills
hotel because I realized that if I went
to the Beverly Hills I was a 21 years
old I got invited to a lunch meeting and
I walked in I'm like Russell Simmons
there's Lior there's all these music
moguls and entertainment moguls and I'm
like this is what everyone is you don't
have to have a room at the hotel to come
to here for lunch I was like what I can
buy an $8 set salad and sit here for 10
hours and I did every day and that was
my office and then people started
recognizing me and then it was on me to
attract them hey cat well you're here
again you know whatever just to get a
face and now all the sudden after six
months I put myself in a position where
I could get a record deal where I could
find somebody where I could call
somebody where I could say hey can I buy
you for five million to Rupp I apologize
it's the name of the show thank you very
much what scares the [ __ ] out of me is
how unbelievably true that is how an $8
salad for that cost is the arbitrage and
how somebody in Iowa that's listening to
this story right now in the rural part
of Iowa has something 37 trillion times
more powerful than your ability to be in
a place to pay $8 for that salad which
is called direct messaging on Instagram
what scares me to no end is that people
will spend 80 trillion hours on dwelling
and complaining and worrying about what
they don't have but we live in fumble
[ __ ] Iowa listen to these two
right now and not reeling somewhat they
do have which is us two schmuck O's with
all our charisma and all this
still didn't have something called
Instagram diem and the 21 year old you
would have stayed on that couch and DM
for 19 [ __ ] hours cuz you would have
bled for it and then there would have
been one yes and that is such a real
story right now for anybody listening
not just people that happen to be in
city areas where this [ __ ] could happen
the serendipity of creating that for you
now is literal but people then hear me
say that because I put out that content
and they give up after twenty nine
people that they DM and then they DM me
and they're like Gary you're [ __ ]
full of [ __ ]
I deemed a bunch of people I haven't
gotten my music out there or sold my
t-shirt I'm crazy and I reply I'm like
hey Carl
with three followers I'm like how many
people have you DM and they're like
twenty-nine I'm like go [ __ ] yourself
you sat there for [ __ ] 1215 hours a
day
I think Cayenne onto that you can do
anything else so I think a lot of people
do you loose NDMS don't even actually
know how to send the proper DM I agree
so people by the way real quick cuz I'm
gonna add on to it there's been plenty
of people that want to the right places
that lost you had the right tack to
start the conversation with Russell
Simmons it's my life I'm on the other
end of this now it is fascinating to me
to watch people go with selfish behavior
in their one setting this dip this
moment to get something to happen when I
write anything I apologize 99.999% of
the time to tell me what I can do for
them yeah it's the whole thing about
this it's like any as entrepreneurs
there's one rule of thumb we have to
create value if you obsess as humans
right if you obsess on value and wake up
how can I provide value as a husband as
a boss or whatever in the long term it's
gonna pay off and always you won't you
won't have the ability to pick up all
the opportunities right one thing that I
do that really helps me helps me I asked
myself a very simple question what I
recommend myself as fill in the blank
what I recommend myself as a dad as a
CEO as a business partner if the
answer's no why and what am I doing
wrong when it comes to Dee
I feel like people want to know like
what's in it for me so when I write an
email I could spend three hours on an
email sleep on it review it edit it how
can I make it shorter is the caption
punch here if I was the recipient how
would I react to it like it's not like
just I'm gonna DM and boom it's like how
do I get this person to respond in the
way that I want the response to happen
and I don't believe in real quick yep
and what we're painting for everybody
who's listening is look the [ __ ]
Internet has given everybody in that
back it doesn't mean that you can hit a
fastball and so the work you put into
having the ability to hit a fastball but
the fact that we're now in a place where
everyone gets in that bat which is not
the case pre-internet is bonkers bonkers
[ __ ]
you're a genius about this damn thing
though because like I got a lot of
layers to get to me I have my assistant
voicemail even let people screen my
email but I checked my own social so I
actually to your point now that you
bring it up the guy that does all my
merch for my company 29 or 29 this race
company we have the end me and you know
what he said he created a win-win I'm
sorry he created a no-lose win wins
don't work because if I say a win-win
way you talk about this - no no I like
where you're going when you have a
win-win Gary might win here and I might
win here that's not a win-win
that's a Gary's dominating the win oh no
losses oh there's no risk that I can't
lose he sent me at the end and said hey
send me your logo I'll send you a bunch
of samples of stuff no costs no risk no
anything if you like it I love a shot to
work with you I'm like okay I sent it to
him a day later I get a FedEx with these
amazing product line and I'm like done
hundreds of thousands of dollars later
we talked about this earlier and it's
great for everybody listen it's about
doing instead of talking people the Emmy
all day long Gary I want to work for you
for free okay that was amazing like if
you think about it that sounds win-win
no losses Gary I made this and then we
look at it our team looks at things that
are made with my content we 99.999% the
time don't even hear you when you say
you're gonna work for free
yeah action always action I had invited
um I went to a dinner party with my wife
and they went around the room and they
asked everyone to name three people that
were alive they'd want to have dinner
with and you came up Oh a Gary Buffett
this one that one but when it came to me
all three of mine were rappers and the
reason was I wanted to meet the three
people that changed the course of my
life as a 14 year old kid growing up in
New York so at the end of the dinner I
called my ten I I invited the ten most
influential artists in my life to my
house for dinner and they all came it's
cool I knew two of them and people like
how did you get Rakim man how did you
get Big Daddy Kane and I'm like I asked
them in a no-lose and they came people
want to help people yeah it's really
crazy because again it's super important
because I want to make sure the listener
gets value you put up enough w's on the
board and had enough social currency to
pull off that Hail Mary which is amazing
right on the flip side it's also how you
got there because the 21 year old you
that had nothing was willing to ask a
hundred people to get one yes yes okay
that's why I'm fired up so for everybody
listening if you've put enough wins on
the board you're probably more likely to
get 7 out of 10 yeses than you think and
for everybody who's the 20 year old you
and me that nobody knows at all or gives
any [ __ ] you will get a 1 out of 400
how do I know that because you and I are
exactly the characters that say yes out
of that 400 once every thousand times I
still do it me too which is why I'm
saying it again yeah this is a very
important conversation and because we
grew up in the same era I [ __ ] on these
entrepreneurs in this era you gave me
the Internet [ __ ] you [ __ ] you this
internet thing [ __ ] you man first of all
I would have definitely not graduated
high school and second of all I would
have made some crazy [ __ ] happen like
you've got it so easy right now yeah I
mean I remember we're not just up to
that point Gary when I was starting out
at Marquis Jet I was looking for my
first customer and I didn't have a
database I don't have sales
or slide no way to get lead the only way
I could get a lead was to show up where
we're with this this is like in 99 right
but I don't go with rich people where I
didn't we didn't have you in a pager Oh
what did you have a pager 9/11 pager I
probably have like oh but there was no
but you had that pain journey like that
cool I had to show up like that no email
list and I heard about this event called
Ted this conference had Monterey
California I'm like there's got to be
rich people at Ted so I flew 16 hours I
connected in Chicago landed in LA drove
five hours to Monterey and I get to the
event and I recognize immediately like
you can't get into Ted without a
credential and I'm like that's socialist
you need a credential so I just traveled
16 hours I need a sail so I go to the
coffee shop and I realized that every 15
every hour and a half people are coming
in and they're ordering lattes and
muffins because they're on break they
have credentials that are on break at
the conference so I'm like so the next
day I showed up at the coffee shop and I
stole no I bought every single muffin in
the store I controlled all the muffin
inventory in Monterey California I leave
and the first break comes and the guy
comes like I'll velocity and a muffin
the guys like you can have a lot but
we're out of muffins he comes back out
like I'm so sorry sir I overheard you
can I actually have a muffin would you
want one he's like well he's like no no
you could take one I says well what do
you do we start talking I said I want to
she's a jet company and goes get out of
here it's like I'm actually and this
really happened to me I'm actually in
the market for a private jet he goes do
you mind if we sit down and talk about
her like mr. qualified you can sit
wherever you want is it bad absolutely
and he was my first sale Josh Kopelman
from half Kaja and that's how my first
sale but like but if you think about
it's actually stunningly unbelievable
and wildly not it's incredibly practical
you know who your customer is go there
what pisses me off and this is why he's
telling the story and it's an
interesting take is that's amazing and
epic and iconic of a story you can lay
in your [ __ ] bed and email and DM
people like what is the matter
with people like back - nothing is
impossible well the Internet has made it
uncomfortably easy and yet people are
losing [ __ ] you I think it goes back
down to what I said earlier even deeper
than the DMS Gary Schutt is is
negotiating your goals and I think you
asked me about entrepreneurship and I
said you know people want to get happen
quicker and speed up the process and
this and that but I also think it's easy
to negotiate your goals it's easy now to
say like I'm not gonna do this I'm gonna
try this I'm gonna throw and like people
don't stick with things night most
people will do 95% of the same thing Jes
they actually don't it sounds good like
there's there's a really deep psychology
on this that people have to rep and by
the way there's nothing wrong with it
like why do you want to be a billionaire
why do you want to start a business like
this is what goes into like a very deep
conversation which is people do things
they think they're supposed to do they
don't mean it when you mean it there is
no other option when you mean it there
is no other option when you don't mean
it because you think it projects well or
it's the thing you should do or your
parents want you to or you think it's
cool or I'll get you girls or it sounds
fun the deeper layer that the deeper
layer of that of meaning it comes from
wanting it and I could say if someone
said to me what's the Silver Bullet of
being an entrepreneur I would say you
have to really want it and then people
laugh I really wanted the promotion I
really wanted to win the lottery they
don't understand what I'm talking about
I can look at someone in their eye and
tell right away if they want it or not
if they're willing to go through the 18
couches that I went through and I'm not
I've plenty egg on my face - you gotta
want it so bad that the obstacles don't
mean anything so if you do 400 d-ends
and they don't hit it doesn't mean
anything you're on dm1 and it starts
with and when you're really there you're
like almost evil about it and you're
happy nobody replied like where I go is
a scary place where I'm like like I hear
that I'm like yeah like I'm like I want
I want disgusting
like I want like I mean it if I hit 400
DMS and it comes back goose egg I get
crazy I'm like uh-huh I'm like you
[ __ ] are gonna be real sad when you
see this DM in six years yes you'll it's
real few like I'm on some real chip on
shoulder I'm gonna [ __ ] kill your
mother [ __ ] will you keep then it comes
to business then real no I need access
to everything like in real life I don't
want to kill your mother but in business
I like like when I watch athletes play
like I love people that like I love
draymond Green like that's who I am as
an athlete [ __ ] you and all cause I'm
gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] you see I think I think
it's everything because if you don't
have that attitude and other buckets of
your life it like it's everything it's
you create to create an environment in
your head that no matter what you're
gonna get it done but real quick and I
remember because you're part ownership
in the Hawks is a good comp the I'm
always fascinated by this you're on the
field football game right that's a rough
[ __ ] sport you're breaking people's
[ __ ] faces triple zero game over
everyone comes to the middle and you're
like hey how Sarah Ben I actually feel
that in my business life like in the
context of business I'm gonna break your
ankle and like I don't give a [ __ ] and
[ __ ] you and I want the whole crowd the
reason I've become friendly with Novak
Djokovic is like he's one of the few
people I've reached out to ever because
I'm like [ __ ] there is only one
thing I see on earth right now that I
completely wish I could do which is be
in center court at Wimbledon against
Roger Federer and know every [ __ ] in
that stadium and everybody who's
watching is rooting for Federer when
know that goes into that zone when he's
like basically like [ __ ] all of you I
get crazy he was gonna back of my neck
right now and goose bumps Novak when
he's against Federer in center court and
Wimbledon like happened this year and
the entire world is like
let's go Roger let's go Roger when he
hits a big shot and everyone goes quiet
the chemicals in my book like all I want
to do is be in that moment because
nothing excites me more to look at every
single person
the crowd of like what's up with your
boy dick listen if there's one thing we
agree on
it's that that's the way I'm wired and
that's does is it makes you not be
scared of losing you actually already
set it up to enjoy the losing when I
took my book living with the seal to the
publishers I got 11 rejections and all
it did was make me be like I can't wait
my brother AJ and I have a sports
representation business we just went
through a draft class right we got a ton
of nose when I tell you I can't wait to
see those [ __ ] in real life in six
years and look them dead and if I'm
already doing it because there's some
kids that said no three years ago that
are already not doing as well as they
thought they were gonna do and their
agents don't give a [ __ ] about them
anymore because they're not gonna make
any money and I would have [ __ ]
taking care of them for life I look at
them dead in the face and say you [ __ ]
up dick listen anger is a really angry
to be Gary
it sounds wildly aggressive it's
actually an unbelievably good oxygen for
its deep merit-based competitiveness it
is
I think listen I think it whatever you
have to pull whatever emotion you have
to pull from people say like get rid of
your anger it's negative I hurt to me
there's like fuel I need a little anger
if you know it's fuel I need it it's a
hard thing to channel consistently and
it there's a negative it's funny just to
play out the story to give context cuz I
think all these things have layers it's
funny I'm not angry at any of these kids
I'm devastated for them which then
manifests me liked it like it's like
it's like this incredible like all I
want to do is have dinner with 11 people
that said no to your book and you and
like just sit I love that [ __ ]
I love but I also like losing like if
you're gonna mean that person you also
have to be the person that when you're
wrong you're like man you saw it I
didn't [ __ ] see it I'll take that l
so I love sports bro you win and lose
entrepreneurships hidden right now Accu
hires
like it's just not sports right 182 279
that's what it was you know yeah I mean
there's score you can use bank accounts
as scorecards and they're kind of man
but before there's a lot of hiding
there's a lot of manipulation in that
we're just like you're watching every I
wish everybody recorded every single
action then you could see it more
because that's what sports is we're
watching all of them all the minutes I
think also at the end of the day we can
talk about this as a great conversation
you know coming back to your question
about entrepreneurs and what I see at
the end of the day man we humans we all
want the same thing what do you think
the one thing that we all want is I
think it's happiness factly we want to
be happy so if you're happy all four you
know things make people have different
things make people happy people are
driven by different things when you said
my dad's a family man plumber you know
like I was like so awesome like because
I know that like I know some like people
that felt different like to your point
there's 7,000 ways to be happy this is
about self-awareness of how you tick not
how you think he should dick my brother
asked me my son is a swimmer he's young
10 years old and my brother asked me how
my son was doing his swim and I said you
know he's doing really good it did it up
but he doesn't have the eye of the tiger
yeah and he's a great swimmer but he
does just doesn't have my brother said
that's ok as long as he's happy yep and
I'm like no my son would be happy
playing minecraft and eating haagen-dazs
every day and fortnight on the couch
that's not what I want I want him to be
to live up to his potential and I don't
see how anybody because that a different
framework than your way your parents
went about it I'm just curious because
it was interesting to hear you like when
you just said that I went back to the
beginning of this podcast think about
the freedom your parents gave you and
were they into the guiding aspect is
that why you run a basketball team or
not I'm just curious their potential so
like when I look at myself and I'll
answer it this way I don't want to be
the 80% version of me right I don't want
to grow up and be like okay you could
have been built Vayner to this but you
only took it here within yourself I
understand you know I understand my
parents their scorecard was how they
raised their kids that's what made them
happy my mom's whole life
I remember going to this grocery store
and someone my mom got into
confrontation I'm like I can't believe
my mother even has a life outside of our
family I didn't react like this their
whole life was about building my family
yep that was it that's what made them
happy yep my life is bigger than that
not in a bigger it's just got more
buckin wide wider so for my family
that's their deaf happiness to them was
taking care of their kids putting them
in college giving them a bar I got it
and for me it's I want to number one my
standards are high man I don't want to
write a book I want to BES what do you
want to impose that on your children so
that's mean for me when you went there
I'm like I have no interest in my kids
taking on my characteristics in any
shape or form I just want them to be in
love and respect their characteristics
as much as I do mine oh that's fantastic
yeah they're not then I to your point
everybody do their own way I'm just
curious where you're going with it my
kids are on their own journey and
because I used to play basketball till
midnight every night and my son wants to
play for at night I can't tell him to go
play basketball there on their own
journey but I do want them to live up to
their potential I just sat with a
financial advisor and he said to me what
would you rather give your kids a
boatload of money or a boatload of life
experiences I want my kids to experience
and see what they like on their terms
are yours on on both like I want to know
I want to get amazing about like your
small while we're talking about this
because a lot of people listening I have
zero point zero zero interest in ever
getting into anyone's actual personal
way of parenting because that's
everyone's got their own uniqueness and
they should I love the macro
conversation of this game because where
I go into this is kids are living in a
reality that is intuitive to where their
world is going versus the world we came
from I think so much about eSports for
that reason it's changed the last 24 to
36 months but the demonization of
parents um you're not doing that but I'm
just I'm using this as an example there
are a ton of parents out there who have
taken their kids
of the path of becoming all-time great
professional eSports players because
they deemed that not being a thing and I
think about that every day my parent
things are work in progress guys I'm
figuring out as I go I don't I don't you
know I have four kids they're all
undertake I'm curious about four night
all day and haagen-dazs as actually
being the stepping stone to actually
winning to actually getting full
fulfillment I really believe that like
I'm debating it for myself I'm
fascinated by that because because I and
it sounds like you too for that matter
I didn't do anything that gave people
confidence that I was up to something
when I was a lemon I was doing
everything off the reservation I was an
immigrant kid everybody had to get good
grades I was getting FS I never clicked
into wanting to good grades for myself I
clicked into this is all horseshit and I
and I always wonder what are the 10 and
12 year olds thinking right now that we
can't see and I feel like some of them
are exactly where I was and I think
about that listen again I think I can
always speak for myself and just so you
guys know my kids have glitches just
like your kids have glitches
everyone's got glitches you know it's
like you think though you sold a company
it's like I got the same my kids don't
get out of a carpool line because they
have anxiety the same kind of stuff
everybody deals with and I don't know I
just know that I want to give them as
much appreciate this I want to take even
the four of them out of the equation I
just think you're a creative thinker and
it's just an interesting conversation
for me you know just I think we're too
interesting time I think people are in
deep [ __ ] in thinking they know where
the world's gonna be in 15 to 20 years
when I think about what 5g is gonna do
as an infrastructure and what that opens
up you got [ __ ] Elon Musk today talk
about like living on Mars like people
are like people don't get it like like
we FaceTime people in [ __ ] China and
it costs $0 the people that were making
decisions for us didn't have phones that
got off a wall like like it's [ __ ]
crazy out here
and it's about to get wildly crazier you
think technology's advanced now this is
dog [ __ ] there's a [ __ ] pager Agron I
know you agree so
imposing today's reality against kids
that are gonna live in a world that's 15
years from now looks nothing like today
and we must hedge for that and when we
think about [ __ ] gary's president but
you know what i mean it's fun yeah i
know that makes sense to you yeah my
products of that yeah it's like kids
talking about rap in 1985 in [ __ ]
Long Island rap wasn't even a [ __ ]
genre to people it was a fad rock and
roll the internet was a fad people
laughed at my [ __ ] father when I
launched an e-commerce wine business the
internet was a fad [ __ ] tik-tok and vine
the whole [ __ ] thing was a fad
do you understand what's coming [ __ ] you
Party Party shots what do you want
people to know you got a lot of people
listening well first of all I want to
thank you for the opportunities is super
cool I've wanted to do this for a long
time you know we connect once in a while
but it's grandma it's good to see two
like arm-wrestle house Manor speakers
going okay how's uh how's Boehner
speakers going one thing that everybody
should know is I think you guys saw
about 16 months ago we started Boehner
speakers I up with my agency a Zack
Nadler he's now the CEO of that it's
been really fun he's actually in the
room while we're talking and one of the
key targets for us was Jesse because we
were looking at things that arbitrage
who is way better than people realized
at this exact second they are at this
thing so it's exciting that you're with
us Straight Talk because that's what I
love about you how's it going
it's been great Zacks been amazing I was
hesitant to do it because I was glad
yeah so I mean I just so you guys know I
started speaking about three years ago I
wrote a book the book became a number
one bestseller was amazing but it
launched me in a completely different
direction than I anticipated
I can started getting asked to speak and
the first speaking event I went to there
were 40 people no microphone the guy
said to me speak loudly and slowly you
have 45 minutes and that has led to you
know much bigger stages and I did it all
myself for two years and then Garry text
me and said I remember this I'm starting
this thing
and you know I saw you speak your grade
or whatever and introduced me to Zach
and what goes through the process like
why I might give pricing I get so much
about myself
anything in the process for me was you
know can I do this myself I'm doing it
myself and it was became an easy
decision for me because I fell in love
with Zach and I know you hand-picked
Zach and and and what you guys do at
Vayner speakers and I weighed it all and
it became super simple for me and it's
been a really good process listen after
I sold my last business I'm like I'm
never having partners again right I
don't want partners I want freedom right
you'd work so you get freedom all right
and I have a partner with partnership
with you guys and it's been really it's
been really good and I'm what's been the
most surprising thing I like learning
it's just there has been feeling those
big surprises if you know you guys laid
out exactly what it was been in it
hasn't we've been able to the surprises
that yeah we did it like first time
right this is what we're gonna do and
we're gonna do it and when I was
disappointed in certain things yep
I would say - Zach like I want something
bigger I need more I did and you know
and he would respond so yeah it's been
real like it you like speaking I love it
yeah me too I wouldn't do it if I don't
like it yeah yeah as you get older man
it's like you only have two buckets Gary
you got aggravation versus reward and I
want low aggravation for the most amount
of award if something's high aggravation
even high reward I'm not doing it and
you guys have made it low aggravate you
know it's funny just if you I and many
others can get people to realize you
don't have to wait 250 and some success
to put yourself in a position for that
and you can actually do that at 22 you
just have to be a little patient and a
little more humble but you could be way
happier you and I in a lot of ways did
do that which is what I think led to
this and I think a lot more people can
do it but they have all these
expectations of what they're supposed to
do from 22 to 30 and it [ __ ] them up
it's true and just to add on about the
speaking cuz I just you know I've talked
about walking in and speaking in front
of 40 people and then you know usually
as entrepreneurs man it's okay to start
small and I just want to say first okay
it's okay to start small you start small
you think big you scale it fast
something my wife always says you start
small think big and scale it fast and
that's the way we've been able to do it
it feels really authentic and grassroots
when I wanted to get into tech the first
five public things meetups events I did
this is in 2009 when Wine Library had
gone from three to sixty million the
first five things I did was cold email
conferences in the tech world an offer
to set up a table and pour wine I was a
bartender at the first a Robert Scoble
Jake ooh event a Technorati conference I
I literally the first five event I found
a picture of me and AJ recently at a
tech cocktail event in which was a DC
Meetup
I was the help that was after real
success most people don't have the
humility to do that with no success
yeah 18 couches I live character for her
brother thank you thanks for being on
let's go Justin
[Applause]
I think it's he had couches could be a
real framework for either a book or a
talk because I really think and you saw
is owned in on it I think if you can go
deep in the way that I've gotten deep
into like fear and insecure like if you
go deep into the network you built which
then became the foundation of everything
you've pulled off and the pattern
recognition of human arbitrage when you
over deliver and you ask for less in
return I think there's a real unlock
there for you and I think the framework
of 18 couches could be a really cool
starting point yeah and the mindset of
me when I was on 18 couches was I'm a
millionaire they just haven't paid me
yet I saw I was thinking that's how I
was thinking I've owned the Jets for a
long time right exactly that's a tough
that's a tough one though I'm gonna pull
it off